I like to show off myself as being in
just my natural habitat which is pretty
much just in my bed Lili Reinhardt is
keeping it real with her fans the 22
year olds Riverdale star spoke to ET in
NYC along with her on-screen mom machen
amick about why she's so open and honest
on social media while not putting on a
show you know like I'm I don't know I
just I'm not trying to look perfect I'm
not trying to show off this all of this
glamorous you know my life in general is
not extremely glamorous I just I do a
lot of really cool and glamorous things
but that's not like my day-to-day and
Lily's TV mom is super proud of her
on-screen daughter gushing to et about
the actresses maturity for her very
young years she's incredibly wise I
think she's an old soul and she's very
comfortable in her own skin and
especially being thrown into Fame so
quickly and intensely she just stands in
her truth and is very comfortable and in
speaking her truth and even if it goes
against like whatever the norm is but
she didn't stop there
Mei Chen also praised Lily for her
social media messages just talking about
body consciousness or mental health
awareness and and then just being real I
think with using her social media to
just be an average girl that just
happens to be an actress and I think
that's great for young viewers that look
under her Lily what is one thing that
you had learned since working with
nation there was surprise audiences
machen commands the set when she walks
she walks in and she she knows her Worth
and her value and she knows her value of
her performances so she you know takes
her time gets to that emotional place
that she needs to get to and doesn't
rush her and I very much appreciate that
the duo also dished on the
misconceptions of fame something they
both had to adjust to quickly in their
careers I think the biggest thing that
people don't understand
nowadays is that being a socialite or
being you know being famous for being
famous is very different than being an
actor and being an actor if you really
are if you take your craft seriously
it's a technique that you work on and
you perform so sometimes that that line
is blurred I think sometimes yeah like
it's very different from people who walk
outside daily like me I amend the
radiographer is already it's like
absolutely not we put on our sweats we
go home and work warmed up food yeah
[Applause]
[Music]